so I've noted this a few times already
if we are going to deal with the current
pandemic in a way that would even come
close to being called successful and
again now when we talk about success
we're talking about how much can we
limit the number of people who die
because the number is climbing rapidly
and it's a it's it's a question of
limiting that number sadly if we're
going to deal with it in anything that
would approximate a success it's going
to likely depend on our state governors
it's not going to happen because Donald
Trump's a direction gives some kind of
unified and and Wealth's well appointed
well crafted strategy and in fact we're
seeing Donald Trump increasingly push in
the other direction it's becoming very
much obvious that Donald Trump is all
but completely committed to reopening
the country letting it rip as dr.
Anthony Fauci sort of characterized it
on Easter Sunday April 12th now it's
still possible that the numbers will be
so ugly by that point and we'll look at
the numbers later and it seems to be
going in that direction it's possible
that the numbers will be so ugly that
Donald Trump will be talked out of it
even by people as incompetent as Jared
Kushner who apparently has a hand in
everything he's supposedly going to be
not not only is he gonna fix the
israeli-palestinian conflict Jared
Kushner is expected I guess to deal with
coronavirus as well despite having no
experience whatsoever in infectious
disease and we've been thinking about
how different state governors are likely
to react to Donald Trump wanting to let
it rip on April 12th because remember
still now at nearly the end of March
more than half of state governors have
done nothing yet as of two days ago 30
of 50 states had no state-level
directives about shutting down
non-essential businesses self-isolation
staying home schools etc now many of
those states had individual cities that
may have made such determinations but 30
of 50 that's 60 percent right that's
three-fifths weren't even doing anything
yet imagine the insanity of talking
about let's open it back up when 30
states haven't yet even closed anything
down
it's completely crazy so when they talk
about April 12th understand that many
states nothing's changed those states
are just standing by and his business as
usual which makes this all the more
absurd there we gonna reopen from never
having closed but the most important
thing here is if there is anything
positive and we're desperately looking
for silver linings everyday and there
aren't many it does seem that more and
more governors are just not going to
follow Donald Trump's direction they are
going to say no to Donald Trump and
they're going to do what's right for
their state which is likely to stay shut
down for what is unfortunately a
relatively long period of time we've got
New York Governor Andrew Cuomo clearly
not on the same page as Donald Trump and
talking about more closures more
limitations as we get into April and
eventually going going into May
California Governor Gavin Newsom
he's very clearly operating under a
completely different sort of set of
facts based on the last thing he said
the extension of stay-at-home orders in
California it's going to go for a while
even in Texas where lieutenant governor
Dan Patrick has been completely unhinged
and talking about sacrificing
grandparents in order to save the stock
market for their grandchildren you even
have the governor there Texas Republican
governor Greg Abbott who's pretty bad he
now is at least endorsing the
stay-at-home orders that individual
cities in Texas have put in place I know
it's not that much they're doing it
anyway it doesn't change anything that
Greg Abbott endorses it but it is a good
sign and then you've got Arizona
Governor Doug Ducey who says public
health must come before the economy yeah
that's true
South Dakota Governor Christie nomes
says business activity must be limited
not relaxed at this time and in many
ways this is going to become and it is a
story already about states rights versus
the federal government which is an issue
that it's an issue that is a common
political debate but I'd certainly
didn't expect on day one of this fiasco
that one of the greatest determinants as
to how this goes was going to be the
issue of states
rights versus the federal government and
it probably wouldn't be the issue if we
had competent science-based leadership
coming from the oval office rather than
doctors stand on stage but they
basically shut their mouths while Donald
Trump brags about this that and the
other thing that he claims he did while
sometimes during these press briefings
not even talking about the case numbers
or the death toll it's very difficult to
imagine now thinking about Massachusetts
I don't see Republican Massachusetts
governor Charlie Baker and a lot of
other governors jumping onboard with
April 12 especially when we are hearing
about more school closures more business
closures extending the school closures
here in Massachusetts and in other
places and especially when you look at
the numbers which we will look at later
I hope that governor's will will
maintain sanity now interestingly enough
the governor of Mississippi Tate Reeves
he's going crazy
to stop abortions during the corona
virus pandemic
but he's very much welcomed welcoming
the idea of a wide open on April 12th we
know of course that Mississippi's health
system is a disaster we know that the
underlying health conditions impact
coronavirus mortality rates drastically
it could very quickly get very very ugly
in Mississippi for Tate Reeves well
we'll be watching that and then there
are even discussions starting about the
possibility of States actually putting
in checkpoints at their own borders
imagine for example that you have
certain states that are all in with
we've got a distance whereas other
states are all about let it rip you
could conceivably have state governors
wanting to set up checkpoints at their
borders which is a very complicated
legal thing to do in the United States
freedom of movement between states is
determined by what's called the
privileges and immunities Clause of the
Constitution and it is a pretty
significant restriction on states being
able to erect barriers or block entry to
states free movement between states is a
cut in the Constitution it's very
difficult to do that if it gets to that
point
imagine that Louisiana takes it
seriously but you know Alabama doesn't
or
you could very quickly see that
hypothetical conflict become a very real
legal conflict in some of these states
last thing I want to come back to you
here
from the beginning right-wing media
choosing to entertain Donald Trump's
completely delusional perspective on all
of this has done such drastic and
permanent damage it has led to nearly
half the country or more than half the
country by States maybe not my
population to essentially believe that
this is no big deal that it is going to
kind of just take care of itself we
don't have to do anything that is a
belief that will increase the death toll
the death toll is already higher than it
otherwise would be if every state back
in whatever the date was March 15th or
so where more and more states started
taking this seriously
and said we're gonna shut the whole
thing down now Donald Trump seems
increasingly indifferent to the death
toll he instead during his press
conference talks about stock market how
much money he's gonna give businesses
how quickly he can get businesses
reopened no mention sometimes of the
death toll even if testing there's
barely mentioning sometimes until Donald
Trump now got his hands on this talking
point if we've tested more people in
eight days than South Korea did in the
previous eight weeks or something of
course ignoring the fact that we're a
far larger country with many more people
we're in real trouble here and I'm
hoping because we're desperate for some
kind of silver lining I'm hoping
governor's will help except they've got
to all get on the same page and right
now they are not twenty governors doing
something thirty governors doing nothing
real quick I want to tell you about our
sponsor magic spoon who have done
something awesome they've taken all of
our favorite sugary childhood cereals
that we know we shouldn't eat anymore
and turn them into something you can
actually feel good about eating as an
adult there's four flavors cocoa fruity
frosted and blueberry they taste great
they're crunchy they're sweet like you
would expect this type of cereal to be
but it's perfect for a ketogenic diet
because one bowl has only three net
carbs 12 grams of protein it's
sugar-free gluten-free grain free soy
free once our team tried magic spoon
for the first time we actually ended up
emailing magic spoon back and saying can
you send us more boxes send more samples
they've been a big hit with David Pakman
show
staffers and magic spoon knows how
delicious their cereal is because if you
don't like it they'll refund all of your
money no questions asked and you'll get
free shipping when you go to magic spoon
dot-com slash Pakman and use the code
Pakman that's PA que ma N